it was the death of general francisco  franco that paved the way for juan  carlos to ascend the throne he was  crowned in november of 1975 he surprised  many with his support for reforms the  new key acknowledged democracy and  quickly shed his reputation as Franco's  protege his greatest moment came during  an attempted military coup in 1981 when  armed soldiers forced their way into the  Spanish Parliament but Juan Carlos sent  the soldiers back to their barracks and  went on television to proclaim  unwavering support for the  democratically elected government the  coup failed Dario within his 39 years  rain Spain entered the European Union  and its economy entered a period of  rapid expansion Juan Carlos was last in  Germany in 2011 and he appeared weak and  fragile so in the last few years he has  delegated more and more responsibility  to his son Prince Felipe the princes  popularity has been rising steadily so  this is a good time for him to assume  the throne